Okay, now, I would like to go back to the drawing of a software under test
that I feel like I've drawn about 30 times already
and recall that this provides APIs and most of the time that's we're fuzzing.
Now, on the other hand, the software under test uses APIs like the UNIX Recall,
we could do fuzzing at this level as well and this most often called fault injection when we do that
and run a fault injection, as we discussed, is extremely powerful.
We've looked at examples of both of these and both of them are incredibly useful.
What I like to talk about now is fuzzing of the implicit inputs, we talked about unit too,
where we have non-API inputs to the software under test that affect it's behavior
that turns out that this is often pretty important, and so, how we'd do this?
Well, as we mentioned earlier, possibly the most important implicit input is the timing at which
different threads are on different processors.
This is to say the thread scheduler provides a very important form of implicit input
to multithreaded software under test.
An extremely important technique is perturbing the schedule.
And as far as I know, there isn't a single best way to do this,
and so we find in practices, people do a lot of different things.
One thing you can do is just generate load on the machine.
That is to say, make sure that your testing is not happening on the complete idle machine.
It is often the case that if you test software on a completely idle single core machine,
even if it has multiple threads, those threads will be scheduled in a quite deterministic way.
Similarly, if you have a multicore machine that has more processors,
then your application of threads, there is again a strong possibility it will be scheduled
on an extremely deterministic fashion while you're doing testing.
And if they are being scheduled extremely deterministically, that means that the scheduler
is exploring only a very tiny fraction of the full set of possible thread schedules
and what that mean is concurrency bugs are going to go unfound during testing.
So, generating load by running apps--generating load by running other application is important.
Generating network activity on a machine can also be valuable.
And network activity is interesting because incoming network fax machine
caused interrupt handlers to fire and they cause lots of kernel routines to run
It caused cache lines to be stolen away from your application
and this causes some perturbation of the schedule.
There also exist specialized tool for stress testing of multithreaded applications.
And if you have one that is available too,
it would be an extremely good idea to use it to help task your multithreaded code.
Okay, so I discovered is what I will call external pertubation to the threads
Also possible, previous software to introduce perturbations internally and one way to do that
is to do things like concerting delays before and after acquiring locks
and also around accesses to shared variables.
This entails a fairly high cost--this isn't so easy, but on the other hand, it might be useful.
And I heard a story one time, there was about a group of researchers who are working on
formal methods based tools for finding bugs and threaded codes
and these researchers were having some sort of a competition where each of them try to find
the most bugs in the software under test that they could,
and what happened was, somebody showed up and just put a bunch of sleeps inside the application
and showed that they could find just as many bugs as this super heavy weight,
super complicated formal methods tool.
So, the final thing you can try is what I'm going to call "unfriendly emulators."
Put that in qoutes, I kind of just making up that name.
But these are--it's kind of special virtual machine or other run time
that's especially designed to stress test your application by doing things like
invalidating cache lines, invoking thread schedules in odd ways, and other things.
And so, there are some these kind of things generally available,
and if one of them fits the needs of whatever your software under test is, you should definitely use it.